i'm gonna try and center this a little
bit right
he's not saying rape is okay one of the
grape is okay
damn it um
so what what it is is that
a lot of the time
hear things
that men don't say this is what i've
cause i've been sitting here listening
to the conversation
a lot of women hear things that men
don't say
he's not insinuating that that's okay
he never said that it's okay absolutely
not but the fact that
you jumped to that
that is a that is a crazy thank you that
is far right on that is on the scale to
say that that's he's not saying that and
the thing is my thing is why
how did you get to that conglomerate how
did you get to him saying yeah firstly
i'll apologize because i'm not
sure
i'm not trying to even put that out
especially on your net like of course
but by you implying that a woman what a
woman wears and how she walks
that is okay then for a man to approach
her that implies that it is okay then
for a man to do what she wants because
he likes to do what she looks like
if he wants to talk to her if he wants
to try to get her number if he wants to
make her feel intimidated
because he's trying to get her number
like when i come up to you in the middle
of the night and i say hi miss is that
what you think is that
great all right great is that is that
what the immediate thought is
you coming up to me later if i'm waiting
for a cab had it happened before
like you are six foot something you are
so much bigger than me you coming up to
me at this time of night i'm just trying
to get home i'm not trying to interact
with anyone i just want to get home when
do you ever want to interact
you'll know if i want if i if i come up
to you you'll know if i want to interact
with you so the only time you want to
interact is when you come up to me
if
so this is the great area that we men
get confusing i think so it's like if
women get no attention they're not happy
right
but if they get attention at the wrong
time they're not happy
but if they get attention at the right
time they're happy and men a lot of men
generally do not know when that right
time is to give you the attention
they men generally don't know so energy
so but that's the thing if a man as a
man being a um
a hunter let's say right he sees his
quote-unquote prayer and i know these
people don't like these analogies but
i'm just using it as an analogy right
and he says oh that looks nice i'm gonna
go and see what that's saying right
at what time is it okay for him to do
that
because because because what you're
saying is it's not okay after two
o'clock in the morning
no but it's just after two
because what i'm trying to say is men
generally yeah go for it men generally
don't know
you you can't tell it yeah together
[Laughter]
like men generally don't know
um
when that time is so like you know when
a woman's feeling you right if like
she'll make i if she makes eye contact
you said about the brushing past all
those little things
that's showing a sign that she yes it is
that she's interested and you know it is
because she said earlier i mean this in
the sense of this yeah what time is it
are you saying men should be able to
retire
well hold on this this will satisfy him
if it's dark outside you see it's dark
outside and say if if the girl is with a
group of friends then it might be
acceptable but if it's dark outside and
no one is around there's no need to walk
up to someone like sure you they might
be attractive but there's no need like
there will be other women
that's not the only woman in the world
that you've ever found attractive there
will probably be someone else like you
said women are easy to find
beautiful women
for the other for the other
20 the other 80 do not get beautiful
girls half of them are virgins and the
other half haven't had sex in a year let
me ask you a question do you see why
what do you see why the women are a
little bit
side eye at what you're saying do you
know i i know why they are it's because
they're looking at as the guy that's not
their type no i'm not no i'm not it
doesn't matter if you know if you see
that someone is by themselves
like that and that's he just asked what
would be acceptable and we're saying oh
this would be acceptable and you're
still saying no no you feel that way the
reason why i say that is because you're
not every girl so some girls might be
like leo's two o'clock i just come from
a club yet of course that's the time to
church me no but like the difference i
said if they're with friends okay so if
you're when like you're coming from the
club i would think you would be with
friends no speaking from experience
let's finish
go on most people most girls even girls
we stay together we stay together and
you guys know that oh why are you always
going to the bathroom together we stay
together we're always together so in
that sense yeah that's fine to walk up
to someone because they're in a crowd
but
um
if if it's a one person and then even if
it's one person you're saying they're
coming out of the club they're probably
drunk so why are you wanting to like
approach someone that's intoxicated and
vulnerable exactly
when you're drunk you're vulnerable yeah
because you're intoxicating so when you
drive when you're drunk you're
vulnerable we shouldn't drive out
exactly so that means that the law sees
it as you're completely able to decide
whether or not as an adult whether you
if you drink and drive you're completely
responsible for yourself
what what if you drink and drive it's
not the man's food that you drunk and
drive so when you when you drink and
walk you should be able to be
responsible as well how can you drink
alcohol and walk down the road that you
so think is the most dangerous place
wherein
what you've what men think is uh
hang on let's get some juice i'm sure
some people may be in the super chat
saying some stuff about this so